what are the most common mistakes new
screenwriters make okay
there's a list but the most to say the
three most common ones that I see are
number one not enough story again it's
that old thing
characters can be wonderful dialogue can
be sparkling and even funny as heck but
if the story lays there just flat as a
pancake that story is not going anywhere
it's it's a weak story number two would
be passive central character that kids
killed more scripts than just about
anything I've ever seen and week story
and passive central character they go
together they really go to get fit
together to a passive central character
is a is a hero or heroine you know the
lead down the middle who doesn't really
do anything and life and the story
happen to them they do not happen to
anything or anyone and that is that is a
one way to put your audience to sleep
very very quickly
audience heroes have to be active they
mean the hero is the audience you build
that you build a story so that the hero
is it with lots of flaws and everything
fine yes make them human but they have
certain qualities character of the of
character and of circumstance they have
to be brave that is absolutely essential
but you can put them in you know unfair
injury we care about people who are
being unjustly dealt with they're in a
situation of danger they're funny
they have a sense of humor that always
helps loved by other people there is
this kind of list of things you can do
to keep characters interesting that
allows us to like them
and once we start seeing the nature of
of the hero or heroines major problem
and
the major impossible task before them
hopefully on about page six or eight we
the audience the audience becomes one
person each of us sitting alone and we
project ourselves
psychologically project ourselves into
the hero and then we're along for the
ride
and if that hero doesn't do anything or
doesn't want anything and other people
do all this stuff and all the people
that come in all the secondary
characters are the witty fun urbane
you know loquacious they're they're that
and joking and funny they're all the
funny characters while basically your
central character is more or less
wallpaper it's it's dead and that is
related to something something else
which is the adversary when that happens
in a script almost always the problem is
there is no adversary or there is no
powerful adversary adversary is so
critical people need to work on their
adversary until it is the adversary
should be the strongest person in the
story and I you know when I was coming
up is they oh they have to be equal they
have to be equal in power to the hero no
they have to be much more powerful than
the hero it has to look for most of the
movie it has to look like the hero had
no bloody way of defeating this
adversary or surmounting this the the
problems being presented by this
adversary what they do it they clink
them and they out try them and drive and
they can make it happen and that's a
story with great conflict with a hero
who is doing things who sucks us in
emotionally that we can ride along
happily for the journey and that's how
that's how the good ones work which is
probably more than more than two through
and made that three or four but the the
next the third I think I would say is
getting it out there too
soon hmm okay that's what destroys most
screenplays it's hard writing this a
screenplay a feature-length screen pip
by heavens that's hard really hard and
it's not necessarily all Pleasant
undertaking labor it it hurts you tear
your hair out you pound your head
against the wall sometimes literally and
uh but finally you got a draft oh god I
did it here it is here it is like I'm
going to get it out quickly as I can and
that's the time of great danger you know
you can't just send it out it is not
ready guaranteed it is not ready so
really this database of cup I mean of
scripts so so I mean really it so some
sounds like you know the the medical
record database they have one on scripts
too they're like oh yes I see Eric Edson
yes on this date he sent us this no now
the coverage is horrible or something I
mean really this exists well I mean I I
have to confess now it's been some years
since I was in the thick of it yes but I
don't think a whole lot has really
changed and except it got more
technological they've gotten better ways
to keep track of stuff ah yeah back then
you had one basically one shot because
one cut the person you're sending it to
if you finally get an agent to say okay
you know what I'll take a look leave me
alone or it's a producer or a friend of
a friend or whatever like that most
often they're not going to read it
they're going to hand it to their reader
and I remember those early on I was
getting phone calls back from producers
and they were obviously reading from
notes they had obviously not read the
script themselves they were working from
leaders notes okay but they have their
time issues too and they've got to use
their time as best they can but yeah if
you get a bad report first time in it is
filed
now it's digital left isn't alized and
you never know ultimately what company
becomes
joined with what company and sometimes
the people they just know each other
even if there are different companies or
and I did this pass through and they
know send me over the report and yes
those those reports can't disobey again
disseminated what if you changed the
name of the script what suppose you
started one called angels flight and
then you said you know what and it's got
a pass and a pass and so you decided to
change it to birds of a feather and I'm
just totally making this yeah but and
and and so birds of a feather has been
looked at and you've worked on it much
more and you've had more time but the
story is very similar I would I would
say my instinct is that you have
probably done severe probably
irreparable damage to your career to
resend something yes okay under a
different title Wow because they have
the plot you know that's one of the
things that reader does they outline the
entire plot before they say and you know
what a good bad or indifferent no I
don't don't do it don't just go around
change entitled because I don't know
they don't like it they don't trust it
then they don't trust you
yes ah so that's the bottom line okay
yes if you really work on something let
first of all let time pass you're not
going to go back at him why we reread
rewritten it in and it's really really
good now and it's five months later and
no forget it put it away and then when
the time comes
and honest it maybe and what they're
looking for in any given year the wheel
keeps turning you know the nature of the
material that they're looking for and
then do it honestly say look you know I
tried this out on you two three years
ago I have been working I mean I still
believe in the idea and I've been
working on it I think it's a great deal
better or you go to somebody who hasn't
read it before because there's always
somebody who hasn't read it before and
say you know a friend of yours
and Nancy or something like that she
read it and she read it she quite liked
it or find another way a back door like
maybe the friend Nancy
but I wouldn't change the title so be up
front play by their little front because
it could hurt you just yeah you need you
need to be upfront about it yeah what do
you think people are scared to be
upfront because sometimes Liars get away
with it we have a sample sir we have a
do we don't have to go into them but
yeah we you have plenty Oh sometimes
Liars get away with it but people
especially people in this business I'm
not saying they're all greatly talented
but a lot of them are a lot of them are
enormous they just have different
talents and writers you know another
different kind of creativity sure and
they mean well you know they're there
they're not inherently you know
dishonest or scuzzy people or anything
like that but they make mistakes and you
you need to learn from their mistakes
and they also amazingly they have long
memories too
you